ça ce sont mes anciens vêtements d'un
chemise qui fait du 54e tour de cou et
ça c'est mon pantalon de taille 62 voilà
comment on devient un héros à
philadelphie il suffit de faire comme le
sergent delgado qui a perdu plus de 30
kilos en quelques mois c'est la presse
qui a déclenché cette guerre contre la
grèce en titrant philadelphie la ville
des gros 30 % d'obèses parmi la
population c'est le record mais il
s'agit aujourd'hui d'un problème
national qui dépasse les limites de la
ville
[Musique]
dans ce pays 61 % des gens sont en excès
de poids 25 % sont obèses le taux de
diabète a augmenté de 33 % en dix ans
nous avons décidé qu'il fallait tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé en amérique
[Musique]
quatrième ville des usa ancienne
capitale du pays philadelphie est une
ville historique c'est ici que fut
signée l'indépendance des états unis
aujourd'hui l'obésité croissante de ses
habitants la fête à nouveau rentrer dans
l'histoire mais cette fois pour des
raisons moins glorieuse la ville croule
sous le poids des gros est désormais
sous l'opprobre
c'est beaucoup plus qu'elle ne pouvait
en supporter
depuis quelques mois les autorités
municipales ont lancé un vaste programme
pour lutter contre les kilos en trop
chacun peut venir s'inscrire et
s'enrôler pour mener cette bataille il
s'agit de s'engager pour un changement
radical l'équipe de basket fétiche de la
ville s'appelle les sixties niners
autrement dit les 76 et ils soutiennent
officiellement le programme l'ensemble
de la ville s'est donc fixé comme
premier objectif de perdre 76 tonnes de
graisse en dix semaines
à l'origine de cette initiative
un homme le maire de la ville john
strict
vous sentez bien vous savez tous que ce
programme ne consiste pas simplement à
perdre du poids il s'agit d'être en
bonne santé et d'avoir un meilleur mode
de vie
c'est l'une des prochaines révolutions
de ce pays
première révolution la mairie organise
désormais de grandes marches à travers
la ville le maire veut redonner à 4
millions de concitoyens le sens de
l'effort physique dans ce pays où
d'ordinaire la voiture a tous les droits
le changement est loin de passer
inaperçue
mais pour john street faire maigrir une
ville entière n'est pas seulement un
acte de philanthropie cette volonté de
changement radical s'explique aussi par
des raisons beaucoup plus terre à terre
un tiers des adultes présentent des
problèmes d'hypertension c'est vraiment
trop tous ces gens vont dans les centres
de santé c'est le contribuable qui paye
alors en tant que maire de la ville mais
aussi en tant que personnes qui payent
beaucoup de taxes pour la santé on a
décidé de mettre au point ce programme
il est fait pour encourager les gens à
changer leur façon de vivre et à être en
meilleure santé
pour mener à bien son programme minceur
le maire a demandé la participation de
tous les acteurs de la ville y compris
des entreprises c'est ainsi que joyce
link a perdu une vingtaine de kilos
grâce à l'application du programme au
sein de sa compagnie d'assurance depuis
elle est une fervente supportrice du
maire dans cette compagnie d'assurance
chaque fois qu'elles le peuvent joyce et
ses collègues s'encouragent mutuellement
par exemple l'une d'entre elle se charge
d'amener des légumes et de la nourriture
saine pour remplacer l'ordinaire de la
cantine
alors il ya un mais nous des mes légumes
des brocolis des points var
c'est ce que je mange
il suffit de se promener dans les
bureaux pour se rendre compte que joyce
et sa collègue toni ne sont pas les
seuls à avoir maigri
sas et d'orly
elle a beaucoup perdu
[Musique]
je suis heureuse je vais avoir un bon
l'autre pour le mariage de ma fille
elle aussi elle a fondu
miss génisses elle a bien fait les
exercices et tout le programme elle a
vraiment tout respecté
mais avec 22 kilos perdus en dix
semaines joyce détient le record absolu
de l'entreprise un résultat qui n'a pas
été facile à obtenir
mes tiroirs ont toujours été remplie de
petites choses des chips des petits
gâteaux et c'est ça que l'on grignotait
quant on avait faim
maintenant je m'étais hier j'ai du thé
naturel
du thé oriental
l'ag du thé amaigrissant
pour aider ses employés l'entreprise qui
sonne merci à mille paquets distribution
de recettes régime sur internet
gratuites à tous les étages et surtout
autorisations d'investir le hall de la
compagnie pour des séances d'aérobic à
l'heure des pauses
bon allez on va boxer nous a rendu
dingue aujourd'hui au boulot voyons voir
que je me rappelle
joyce et ses collègues s'entraîne
désormais au rythme de trois heures par
semaine un planning chargé elle ne
pourrait sans doute pas tenir en dehors
de l'entreprise
je vois ces gens plus souvent que ma
famille mes amis où mon mari alors
pourquoi ne pas faire ça au boulot c'est
vraiment le meilleur endroit et puis on
se met deux par deux donc vous avez un
partenaire ou carrément un groupe
lorsque vous le souhaitez l'entreprise
vous soutient et elle vous aide à perdre
du poids il vous encourage
c'est ça le vrai truc
le truc c'est aussi une bonne opération
de communication à peu de frais pour
kiston merci car grâce au zèle de ses
employés la mairie va bientôt lui rendre
un hommage public à l'américaine
d'abord appelée geste merci et une
mention spéciale pour de ce qu'ont fait
les 307 employés
ils ont réussi le programme des 76
tonnes et nous voulons les distinguer
voici donc la récompense pour cayston
merci
pour le premier bilan du programme
l'ambiance est à la fête et à la bonne
humeur
d'ailleurs le programme a été baptisé 76
tonnes de plaisir pourtant plaisir et
cure d'amaigrissement ne font pas
toujours bon ménage à la station de
pesage par exemple gare à ceux qui n'ont
pas perdu à ses ou pire qu'ils sont
contrôlés positifs à la prise de poids
avait bu l'eau que vous deviez boire non
non non d'accord et combien de verres
deviez vous boivent
environ 10 je crois d'accord donc vous
n'avez pas vu votre eau et c'est
sûrement pour ça que vous n'avez pas
perdu deux fois l'eau est la seule façon
d'évacuer les saletés de votre organisme
a alors si vous ne buvez pas votre eau
que faites vous eh bien vous stockez les
saletés dans votre corps la conséquence
c'est que vous vous prédisposées à des
tas de maladies on s'en fiche de perdre
du poids parce que là vous n'allez pas
maigrir mais en plus vous allez être
malade
depuis la mise en place du programme les
vendeurs d'eau font donc des affaires à
philadelphie mais aussi les spécialistes
de nourriture alléger comme ses pizzas
avec seulement une tranche de pain et de
la purée de tomate ou bien ces glaces
sans sucre ni les des glaces dont le
prix 4 dollars n'a rien à voir non plus
avec celui d'une vraie glace
[Musique]
une glace normal ça vaut un dollar un
dollar 25 ça dépend du vendeur mais dans
une occasion spéciale comme celle là on
sort et on lui achète ce qu'elle veut
c'est une fois dans l'année alors sur
les stands on réapprend à faire du sport
tant pis pour la morphologie
particulière des obèses ici on ne
connaît qu'une technique la technique
commando
[Musique]
une minute de pompes il faut même pas y
arriver
kendall a 25 ans et elle vient de
découvrir l'existence du programme la
prise de contact est un peu rude mais
elle envisage de s'engager à son tour
dans l'aventuré
je n'arrivais même plus à me souvenir de
l'époque où j'avais fait un effort pour
la dernière fois j'étais avachis devant
la télé lorsque j'ai vu la marche du
maire
alors je me suis dit pourquoi pas
prendre une journée aller là-bas à faire
un peu de sport
je voulais perdre 18 kilos alors j'ai
encore du boulot pour y arriver mais kg
après kg c'est faisable
je suis fatigué
aujourd'hui les organisateurs promettent
un tee shirt gratuit à kendall si elle
passe par tous les stands mais il lui
reste encore le plus dur à faire
escalader un rocher de carton pâte et
avec son poids c'est loin d'être évident
aller un cran de plus
je ne peux pas
agent tremble encore oh mon dieu
j'ai gagné mon t-shirt
quelqu'un l'a joué extra-large extra
large
cet exploit a fini de convaincre kendall
direction le centre de recrutement en
tigresse une signature pour adhérer à
son tour au programme un peu de
documentation et elle se sent déjà plus
légère ah ouais c'est faisable
je bois déjà de l'eau alors ça ne va pas
être dur manger plus de fruits de
légumes je peux le faire
de retour chez elle kendall doit
appliquer la phase numéro un trouver un
partenaire
c'est kim sa tante qui a accepté de
l'accompagner et tout d'abord il faut
évaluer le poids de départ
fait 95 kg non ça ne dit pas 95,7 aux
sans
s'en veut et demi ce nom sans trois
bon ok sans doute
des régimes l ain ont déjà essayé des
dizaines celui ci qu'elle considère
comme révolutionnaire consiste tout
bonnement à redécouvrir des règles de
vie un peu plus saine mais c'est prévu
la progression va se faire en douceur
chaque semaine il faut ajouter une chose
au programme on a une semaine pour
travailler chaque nouveau point
oui ça marche comme ça et tu vois
combien on va perdre c'est ça qui
m'intéresse je pense qu'après les dix
semaines ça doit devenir une habitude
probablement qu'on reprend vite de
mauvaises habitudes
mais au fond de soi on sait mieux ce
qu'on devrait faire
ce n'est pas comme un vrai régime
c'est plus un changement de style de vie
c'est différent
pourtant quand on habite dans une grande
ville les choses les plus simples sur le
papier ne sont pas toujours faciles à
mettre en oeuvre ne serait ce que pour
faire du sport régulièrement le premier
part tranquille se trouve à trois quarts
d'heure de chez kendall mais au début on
est motivés dans quelques mois on va
avoir un nouveau look juste quelques
mois
[Applaudissements]
et puis il y à aussi l'alimentation à
surveiller là ça se complique bien sûr
les légumes c'est facile à reconnaître
mais choisir une nourriture saine dans
une épicerie américaine c'est pour ken
dahl une sorte de révolution culturelle
bien sûr les sodas s'est terminée il ya
trop de sucre je vais boire plus d'eau
plus de glace non plus
le programme de kendall ne donne aucune
indication précise sur l'alimentation
pour sélectionner ses achats elle n'a
d'autre ressource que de se fier à ce
qui est écrit sur les emballages la
plupart de ces produits n'ont rien de
diététique mais tous affirment le
contraire
tiens je pourrais prendre du pop corn
alléger ses light
50% moins gras
je peux prendre ça aussi comme ça
j'aurai ma dose de calcium c'est bon
pour le régime vous voyez sur
l'emballage la comparaison avec d'autres
céréales là il ya plus de fibres
kendall ne sait pas encore lire entre
les lignes du marketing pourtant en
faisant appel à son esprit critique
elles sont bien que la partie n'est pas
gagnée c'est dur de démarrer parce que
je ne suis pas sûr de ce qu'il faut
acheter ou pas des skis et sein de ce
qui ne l'est pas
je sais que les fast-food les gâteaux
les cookies tout ça ce n'est pas bon
mais il faut que je me mette à cuisiner
différemment par exemple cuir mais
animant four au lieu de les faire frire
et voilà il faut changer comme ça jour
après jour et peu à peu je vais y
arriver
[Musique]
difficile de changer les habitudes
alimentaires des américains basés sur le
prêt à consommer à philadelphie comme
partout dans le pays l'alimentation est
considéré comme un service et nourrir
les autres c'est un métier c'est ce qui
a fait la fortune de jean aux le plus
célèbre revendeur de filippis tech de la
ville
[Musique]
il en avait trois sortes au fromage
américain au pro bowl et au fromage
fondu
sas tartine comme ça
cinq ou six tranches de viande de boeuf
saisie au grill des oignons et voici la
plus fameuse spécialité culinaire de
philadelphie le feeling cheesesteak
des sandwichs comme celui ci il s'en
vend des milliers par jour les
philadelphia en raffolent et ont régalé
leur famille et selon le patron joe
vento le fameux sandwich n'est pas en
cause dans les problèmes d'obésité
ce pays est né avec le boeuf il a grandi
avec le beurre je sus fait de boeuf et
de pommes de terre regardez-moi 62 50
ans
et robert
chez gino on a le boeuf dans la peau
dans ce pays la viande est une
institution et personne ne se
hasarderait à s'y attaquer pas même les
vraies institutions
voilà pourquoi ici on ne veut pas
entendre parler du programme minceur de
la mairie et d'ailleurs dès qu'on
prononce le nom du maire
la réplique ne se fait pas attendre il
oublie qu'il ya quelques années il était
dans le business du hot dogs et je ne
voyais pas faire tous fois quand il
était dans ce business avec son frère
jean steve tech c'est pour toujours on
ne va rien changer dans votre resto rien
de ce qu'ils peuvent nous racontez nous
fait peur vous voulez des légumes
parfait ailleurs
le message est clair et pourtant la
mairie continue son travail de sape dans
son programme elle a associé plusieurs
restaurants et surtout l'école de
cuisine de la ville
comme démissionnaire de l'hygiène
alimentaire équilibré les futurs chefs
ont désormais pour consigne de tout
faire pour changer les habitudes
culinaires de leurs concitoyens et dans
cette école réputée c'est parfois la
subversion qui rentrent dans les
assiettes puisque on n'hésite pas à
pointer du doigt les lobbies de
l'agroalimentaire
avec les américains la plupart des
choses sont sponsorisés par les
producteurs de viande et de fast food
vous devez être averti de ça vous ne
pouvez pas oublier ça
il ne s'agit pas de devenir végétarien
mais oui je crois que vous devez prendre
en considération qui sponsorise la
chaîne alimentaire
un discours de méfiance inhabituelle au
pays de l'économie de marché et des
multinationales mais les supporters de
la nourriture saine sont de plus en plus
réticents vis-à-vis des grands groupes
de l'alimentaire joseph schilling le
directeur de l'école les accuse d'avoir
industrialisés à outrance la nourriture
des américains
ce qui se passe aux etats unis c'est que
nous trouvons toujours des substituts au
préfabriqué on ajoute des produits
chimiques que ceci ou cela est ce que
c'est bon pour nous je ne crois pas moi
je suis obligé de prêcher pour l'huile
d'olive en cuisine
les gens croient que parce que c'est de
l'huile c'est mauvais ils ne comprennent
pas que c'est naturel et puis il ya
toujours une salade sur une table
européenne il n'y en a jamais sur une
table américaine
[Musique]
les campagnes américaines sont pourtant
verte mais la plupart du temps ces
chantiers vont servir à confectionner
des plats tout prêts et conservable
vendus sous la marque des grandes
compagnies les cultures maraîchères ont
quasiment disparu
résultat à philadelphie comme dans la
plupart des villes américaines
l'approvisionnement en produits frais
devient un problème
là encore la mairie a trouvé une parade
il s'agit de faire revenir les produits
de la ferme au coeur des villes une
initiative qui se développe en
partenariat avec des associations
farmers market trust est l'une d'entre
elles depuis dix ans elle milite pour
réapprovisionner les quartiers en
produits frais au sein de cette
association on trouve essentiellement
des jeunes comme cynthia cooperman pour
eux il s'agit de réapprendre aux gens à
se prendre en main du point de vue de
l'alimentation
incitations informations distribution de
recettes tous les moyens sont bons pour
détourner les philadelphien de leurs
habituels fast food
beaucoup de gens qui viennent ici sont
tellement reconnaissants que nous soyons
là dans leur quartier ils ne peuvent
même pas croire que quelque chose de si
merveilleux arrive à côté de chez eux ça
les excite vraiment
pour certains l'achat de fruits ou de
légumes frais représentent un petit
effort financier là encore la mairie
apporte son soutien dans l'un de ces
bureaux on peut se procurer des bons qui
permettent d'acheter meilleur marché ces
fruits et légumes frais coûte cher car
ils viennent de loin d'une amérique où
les fermiers sont restés adeptes de la
culture traditionnelle presque un voyage
à travers le temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes à 150 km de philadelphie
dans une communauté amish une communauté
religieuse qui continuent à vivre comme
il ya 100 ans au delà du folklore il
continue à pratiquer la culture
maraîchère et c'est chez eux que
poussent les légumes que l'on peut
quelquefois trouvait à philadelphie
dans ses campagnes reculées les fermiers
ont perdu depuis longtemps l'habitude
d'écouler la totalité de leurs produits
avec l'invasion des produits industriels
de l'agroalimentaire ses fruits et
légumes difficile a conditionné ou à
conserver sont presque devenus des
produits de luxe pour survivre les
petits producteurs ont dû augmenter les
prix ce qui n'est pas pour relancer la
demande
louise et john groff son fermi
l'essentiel de ce qu'ils produisent il
le cultive autour de leur maison et sur
leurs terres tout est naturel sans
produits chimiques ils sont loin des
préoccupations de rentabilité forcené
des industriels
ils font de la nourriture bon marché
mais nous nous disons que la priorité ce
n'est pas le prix c'est la qualité
c'est vraiment la qualité qui compte
nous on veille à ça
les gens finiront bien par se rendre
compte que c'est meilleur pour la santé
je crois que 10 % de la nourriture
aujourd'hui et biologiques c'est tout
nouveau
john et louise son mennonite une
communauté proche des amish sur la table
de la cuisine aucun risque de trouver un
cheeseburger ou un soda ici on suit les
préceptes de la bible dans la vie de
tous les jours et même encore plus dans
la cuisine pour les gens comme louise et
john la ville est un peu une pécheresse
qui s'est fourvoyé dans l'erreur
du coup une fois par semaine john prend
son bâton de pèlerin et n'hésite pas à
parcourir les 150 km qui le séparent de
philadelphie pour amener ces produits
frais un peu comme s'il a mené la bonne
parole en terre païenne
mais malgré toute la bonne volonté du
monde on ne change pas certaines
mauvaises habitudes aussi facilement
[Musique]
première victime de ce style de vie les
enfants
du poulet des spaghettis et des pizzas
c'est tout ce qu'ils mangent jamais de
légumes
c'est dur d'encourager quelqu'un
lorsqu'ils ne veux pas mais vous voyez
les quand même soit en mauvaise santé
la nouvelle génération est donc devenu
la priorité de farmers market trust
c'est sur ces jeunes que compte
l'association pour réduire le nombre
d'obèses à l'avenir farmers market
trustent les encourage à vendre des
fruits et des légumes au sein de leur
collège mais pour eux les produits frais
c'est l'inconnu
il faut que tu te rappelles corps et la
saison de la pastèque est ce que la
saison 7 en plein hiver ou est-ce que
c'est pendant l'été
aujourd'hui il ya toute une génération
qui n'est pas familiarisé avec les
fruits et les légumes ils n'ont ni
l'envié ni l'opportunité d'en manger je
pense que l'obésité ça peut arriver
n'importe où dans n'importe quel pays ce
n'est pas une question liée aux
américains et à leurs gènes c'est à
cause de notre façon de vivre et comme
notre style de vie devient populaire en
europe ça peut se produire ailleurs si
ça nous arrive aujourd'hui ça peut
arriver à paris demain
je suis très bon allez-y non je suis
vraiment très pressé j'ai quatre places
pour le match de baseball faut que j'y
aille un drame en chypre et c'est là on
faire cuire m en souviens que c'est
vraiment trop long
à philadelphie c'est la communauté noire
qui tient de loin la première place au
palmarès de la malbouffe c'est donc chez
eux que l'on trouve le plus de candidats
à l'obésité et aux maladies qui en
découlent
30% de philadelphie 1 sont touchés mais
pour les noirs le chiffre double dans
cette ville les noirs font souvent
partie de ces un habitant sur cinq qui
vivent en dessous du seuil de pauvreté à
philadelphie des quartiers réputés moins
sûr situé en périphérie de la ville peu
d'argent dans les bourses autant de
raisons qui poussent les éventuels
supermarchés a déserté le secteur noir
voilà comment elle ce qu est un magazine
de santé pour la communauté afro
américaine établit le lien entre
l'appartenance à une classe sociale et
les problèmes d'obésité
si vous considérez ne serait-ce que la
possibilité de trouver des produits
frais de la nourriture saine et
nutritive elle n'existe pas dans les
quartiers pour
donc quand vous avez une communauté qui
n'a pas beaucoup d'argent ils sont
obligés de faire avec ceux qui veulent
bien de leurs maigres ressources
alors il n'y a que les fast food qui
justement leurs ventes de la mauvaise
nourriture
pour les afro-américains la santé ce
n'est donc pas qu'une question de régime
et d'exercice c'est aussi une question
sociale économique une affaire
d'éducation
c'est tout un système
plus on descend dans les quartiers
défavorisés plus la situation empire
la révérende qui régna franklyn tente
d'y remédier avec son arme secrète un
ballon de basket qui lui sert à nouer le
contact avec les jeunes
mais ici comme le chômage la drogue ou
la délinquance la malbouffe et le
laisser-aller font partie des fatalités
auquel on s'habitue
premier objectif de la référente
stimuler ses protégés mais avec les
laissés pour compte du rêve américain il
faut souvent faire preuve d'astuce et
d'imagination
tout d'abord quand j'exerce mon
ministère à l'église je danse si je
m'assure que les gars danse bien avec
moi là dedans c'est le meilleur moyen de
garder la forme alors je me lance
pendant la prière et on y va tous c'est
comme ça pendant une demi heure on monte
sur l'estrade et on bouge on joue et on
fait ça pendant une demi heure donc
pendant une demi heure vous pouvez vous
dire que j'ai réussi à faire faire du
sport à près de 100 ou 200 personnes
et avec ceux qui ne viennent pas
l'église c'est un peu plus compliqué
qu'est ce que tu peux faire pour ton
corps rien et pourquoi ouais j'aime mon
corps qui aime ton corps mais tu es trop
lourd pour tes 18 ans tu sais que tu
peux faire un infarctus ou une attaque
cérébrale
et toi combien tu perdu récemment
je croyais qu'on avait le droit de shoot
pas un seul avec moi combien tu perdu
récemment peut-être une livre ou deux
d'accord ok tu sais que c'est pas besoin
de perdre plus d'un kilo par semaine
c'est comme ça qu'il faut faire
moi je ne veux pas comme force
je le fais je veux que ça soit moi qui
décide
d'ailleurs je mange déjà - je marche
beaucoup
de toute façon si je dois mourir je
mourrai heureusement je suis encore
vivant
face à ce comportement presque
suicidaire la révérende se donne bien du
mal mais dans les quartiers pauvres
quand on n'a pas de boulot et pas
d'avenir comment s'intéresser à des
questions apparemment aussi futiles ce
que son tour de taille et tu m'écoutes
le nom
[Musique]
depuis qu'elle a adhéré au programme
minceur du maire kendall persévère elle
s'est acheté un vélo avec lequel tous
les jours elle s'impose une demi heure
d'efforts physiques
[Musique]
ça devient de plus en plus facile une
fois qu'on a commencé
et maintenant je peux en faire de plus
en plus longtemps
donc je peux garder un rythme de
progression au lieu de staline et de ne
pas maigrir
au bout d'une semaine kendall n'a pas
perdu autant qu'elle l'aurait souhaité
mais sa constitution physique ne lui
permet pas d'effort trop violent
marchait ça permet de récupérer
voilà comme ça tout doucement
je ne voudrais pas faire un infarctus
tout de même
elle n'a pas l'intention d'abandonner
mais elle elle a une bonne raison
oui parce que moi j'ai un but je veux
maigrir
parce que je veux devenir militaire
mais bon avant de rentrer dans l'armée
il faut perdre du poids
[Musique]